[Music]
it's
God it's
God what's going on everybody Welcome to
our podcast out here in csb I'm with IP
inspiring philosophy and I'm with what
do you mean John McRae in the John
McCrae in the house what's going on
fellas what's going on man good to be
here man uh dude before we turn the
cameras on guys there was a side of Ip
that you guys probably will never
see as long as he acts right as long as
he fulfills his into of the
bargain we'll never release the true
inspiring
philosophy no but um about this
conference guys you know I want you what
do what do you guys think about what's
going on uh what's it doing for the
culture or for the Christian Community
online in particular what are you guys
thoughts about the conference as a whole
gu yeah I think we need more conferences
like this because uh we need to really
start using pointing out why
Christianity is important why we need it
in the world and getting people
connected I actually saw some people
here that came out to a conference we
did in November here and they became
friends of that conference and now they
came back to this so they met at that
conference and now they're coming here
so that's great we want to see more of
that yeah I've never seen this many um
like internet personalities as far as
Christian content creators in the same
place the lineup is crazy it's crazy
yeah John can you speak to that a little
bit about the one the lineup that we
have and then like I guess what it means
to have everybody in the same place in
the same building just connecting like
this yeah no I think like right now too
is a a unique time in really as far as I
can remember because Christianity kind
of switched over in The Last 5 Years
From being something that was like taboo
and people didn't like it was you know
edgy to like make F of it and say it was
Goofy and stuff but the tone has changed
socially too so right now we're at a
unique time where conferences like this
I think are important and then just
having everybody here all in the same
spot you know what I mean I think it's
just it's a blessing because it used to
be like there was fewer creators and
people weren't really talking and
getting along and now we have everybody
that's everybody knows each other you
know what I mean so it's just a really I
feel blessed to just be a part of it
yeah I was just at a conference in
Florida where we both were there was 500
there there was almost 500 here so this
is this is great I mean I've talked to
other people and when they can get to at
least 200 they think that's good but man
500 two conferences I mean that's
awesome this is insane now I got to
admit man um cuz I met you already
unfortunately and what does that mean I
met it means it's a good thing uh yeah
we're close to April fools okay so um I
met IP already um I met David wood you
know met the little met met the crew met
vocab before and stuff like that um r I
was most excited to meet you John cuz
you know you're the newer one no offense
okay um but I was really excited to meet
you because one um you know as you know
IP points out you know there's not a lot
of us uh in the in the you know
Christian Ministry like this in the
internet but I looked up to you and the
way that you formulate your videos the
structure you have the research you do
um I would actually say you too when it
comes to the research you guys do to
make your videos I've like I absorb that
I'm like man how did they get this so
what is that like when you're making
your videos uh the work that you're
putting in you know to to get the
quality and that that that information
that you get yeah no I appreciate that
man um it's just I guess like people are
wired in different ways is the way I
think about it so you have some people
who um are really kind of wide you know
what I mean and they're they're kind of
doing a lot of things kind of quick you
know it's more like um quantity over the
quality but not to say that their
quality is low it's just like some
people are just to be able to do more
I've always been a person that was
actually like lik to go deeper into
things you know what I mean and so I've
always kind of been like that but and
always trying to keep it kind of surface
so for me I'm like I like to just make
sure everything is as tight as I can
make it before I get out something and
like I get paranoid about getting facts
wrong or anything like that so it's was
like I want to just take my time to try
to do my best that I can to try to
represent God as well as I can you know
but but I think I'm just kind of wired
that way too I've always been person
that likes to go deep on stuff yeah and
and same with you you're information
based and you do shorts you do the reals
you do responses and the way that you're
putting the information out you're
quoting Scholars and sources how do you
um I guess avoid making informational
mistakes and if you do what's the
attitude that you will have I mean I
make mistakes all the time just admit
you were wrong I mean like I've taken
videos down I've redone videos it's like
I'm messed up and so you just you don't
let it go to your head you think you
have to always be right all the time
yeah made a mistake made a mistake I
misspeak on live streams sometimes and
if people point it out I I and if I you
know if I see it I'll make a correction
in like the video description but one of
the things I do is I read every day and
I try to read a minimum of 30 pages of a
book yeah apart from reading the Bible
and then I'm I'll read with a
highlighter my highlighter is my
bookmark so I'll highlight important
things and then when I go back through
the book I'll read my highlights again
and then I absorb the information better
so I mean I'm just constantly trying to
add information so I'm like reading
books now for video videos they won't be
out until October so I mean I'm last
year I was reading books that um videos
have just come out now yeah so I'm
trying to work ahead and see what needs
to be done and I'll read books and then
I'll come back you know what I read a
book like three years ago let me go read
my highlights I bet I can add it to this
video I'm currently work on I actually
do something similar to that in terms of
highlighting so what I do is I I I guess
it's basically like highlighting but I
put brackets in there but I write like I
have little little letters that mean
different things to me so like if
there's ever a book I write like an O
for objection and then I'll do a dash
there then I write an R for the response
but I always have these notes and then
at the top of the page I write the theme
but I use that as a reference to keep
going back to the same books and stuff
like that that's good oh man that's
amazing so uh this means a lot I guess
you know not just for me but you know
people who really don't know how to dig
they don't know where to go like they
you know like for me myself I don't like
to waste my money and so if I'm like I'm
interested in the subject I want to know
that okay this book I'm about to buy is
going to give me what I'm looking for
it's going to give me what I want I
don't like wasting my money you know
what I'm saying so digging for
information knowing how to research
correctly is something I expressed to
you before and but a lot of us don't
know how to do that exactly here's what
you do look at a book check up the
author if he's like a if if he's you if
he's written a book on history and you
check his credentials and he's like a
scientist that's a red flag that doesn't
mean he's wrong MH go to the
bibliography how long is it um read
maybe the introduction if he starts
saying stuff and there's noot there's no
like footnote there's like no number
there giving sources yeah that's another
red flag so you got to do that you know
check to make sure their their
credentials in their field uh check to
make sure they're using references and
give that kind of stuff and then you
know cuz sometimes I'll find books and
they'll make claims and then I'm I'll
try to track the claims down using the
internet and sure enough they don't
check out so those little things will
help but but also here's a little simple
fact if you're interested in the topic
and I have a video on it I put a lot of
books in the videos so people have
references go read those books I want
you to that's why there I put so many
quotes and videos because it's going to
give you more resources to use calm down
bro s little yeah getting a little EMP
here
relax God just just a question read okay
what I'm saying is read I'll get angry
if you don't yeah you watch my videos
read the books read the books read the
darn
books footnotes he doesn't have
footnotes he's
bogus see I told you guys little it's
coming out every every now and then
starting to sneak out a little bit got
to hold him back a little
bit just GNA hold him back just a little
bit y'all oh shoot okay so that's
awesome all right so uh few questions I
guess um you said that you know when we
met uh long time coming man you know
finally so you I I'm assuming that
you've maybe seen some of me around or
heard of me what have you heard what did
you
think yeah good question no I um I I I
was just telling Alan par actually um
because I was seeing he hasn't seen your
stuff before but I think you're one of
the best out there for debating against
Islam I think you're definitely 100%
because that's crazy I mean because I've
seen you do stuff that I haven't seen
other people be able to do with like
shik man and you know what I mean so so
I mean I think I mean you're gifted in
your way too
most people do what you do and also know
those sources so that's what I mean it's
like I mean you ask us about research
but you obviously do research when it
comes to like these hadiths and kurran
stuff so it's just like you have your
lane and I think God's like uniquely
gifted you for that lane so I think
you're doing great work bro everything
I've seen from you that was really I'm
not going to cry at all that's what
you're trying to do no you you keep your
you keep your cool when you're you're
dealing with the Muslims and you can
keep them on topic because they are
Muslims have this really devious ttic
it's just whataboutism and and you try
to bring up something and they're just
what about this what about that and
you're good at keeping them on the
actual topic and preventing them from
going off their stupid rabbit trails to
change the topic they always try that
that's freaking that's awesome I mean I
do I do think like what you do is really
needed bro so I was like really
appreciate it and I think you do a good
job too of you can you can use some of
Sam shimon's arguments but it's not Sam
Sam's my boy I love Sam I love Sam I
always love Sam but sometimes he know
sometimes he get out of line a little
bit but but you can do it and you can
keep the cool and you just got a good
Persona about you too so I appreciate
your work too man well that's a humbling
to hear from both of you guys you guys
are my you know y'all are up there for
me so I watched y before I started a
YouTube channel I'm here smiling and
joking with y'all so he's lying he's
actually taller than me so I definitely
am it's not that's that's not a joke you
know it's um I could barely see him
however he almost stepped on me
I asked them to come hoop with us too by
the way I might surprise you I I want
you on my team I got I got I got skinny
ankles I can turn real quick you turn
change direction real quick you look
quick not at your old
age break a hip I'm younger than you I'm
still in my 30s John you're in your 40s
he that's tough you guys are married
you're both married to to other people
not not each other no not anymore I okay
what happened with that oh it's a long
story okay well you know I'm pretty sure
we would want to hear that one day um
but you're married to new people now yes
women women nice I am also married
married to you said it like you guys are
married right I was like wait
what so I just got married few weeks ago
guys I appreciate that um you guys are
into apologetics you're into this online
Ministry what is that like in a married
life um managing that TimeWise you know
your relationship um how do you guys do
that and you know is your wife you know
into what you do does she not care uh is
she like get to me when you're done you
know do you have a time limit that you
got to you know be editing or whatever
what's that like guys yeah yeah it could
it I don't know I work from home and
that helps so uh such some is there in
the house if she needs something I can
take a break and do it yeah and I can
set my own schedule but I mean she knows
this is like my life like I love to
study this stuff so I'm just going to
keep doing it so it's also a hobby so I
mean like you know she she encourages me
and respects me and and allows me to do
that stuff as long as I make time for
her and her daughter and I'm not like
just totally invested in it so you know
you I I the way I do it is I I could
take breaks throughout the day like I
need to get my mind some relax I have to
relax my mind decompress a little bit
let me help her with the dishes or let
me help her fold laundry and then when
we do that then I can go back and keep
writing or working on something that
kind of thing for sure what about you
Joe um that's a great question man now
so I I generally think I got the best
wife in the world hands down like for
real she's always been super supportive
she holds down the house she takes care
of stuff like just so that way I can do
what I do you know and so I mean without
her I literally could not be doing what
I'm doing you know what I mean she's
such a blessing but um I like I guess
what's hard being a YouTuber at least me
doing events especially is you're always
thinking about YouTube and I think this
is how all YouTubers are but you just
don't stop thinking about what's your
next video what's going on in the world
right now what are you going to miss you
know what I mean how am I going to work
this video so I can't shut it off
typically but what I I do is I rent out
an office so that way I can try to
separate work from home a little bit you
know so when I come home I try but I
just try to just I just keep having to
get back cuz I'll fall back to working
at night when I get home work until time
to bed and then you know but I always
just try to like get back on and be like
no I got to shut everything off and then
spend time with the kids and stuff but
it's a struggle sometimes it is but but
I mean thankfully my wife never is like
you know mad at me about it or you know
what I mean it's like she's just great
so is she into it is she into yeah yeah
so yeah now I have her posting on the
social media accounts and stuff she's
helping with that yeah but she yeah
always bounc ideas and stuff over her
too so and my wife spell checks all my
videos which is great she can be passive
aggressive She's Like You misspelled
that word that's so fun that's not how
that supposed to be pronounced yeah
thanks honey yeah my wife is the biggest
troll she's yeah she trolls not just me
but Muslims as well so she got like fake
accounts and whatnot Tik Tok and you
know so she'll be in the comment section
like what you know I you know you know
what so she she and and she you know she
grew up she knows how to roast so she
knows that she's in that that lifestyle
where it's talks mess to her she's the
wrong one she ain't going to get mad or
emotional she's going to clap back and
and make everybody laugh at you and do
it you know and so it's it's funny while
if somebody's coming at me I don't have
to respond cuz she's killing them in the
comment section but I um I I couldn't
like what you said about your wife man
our wives are so important I couldn't I
can't imagine myself being married to
somebody else and doing this because she
l loves it she loves the Lord one and
she loves apologetics she loves learning
about God and Theology and going deep
into it she loves the argumentation
learning new arguments you know being
even tested UNC like she likes to try it
you know she's she she's good herself so
um I couldn't imagine you know being
married to someone else I just couldn't
we're so compatible in that area so it's
it's really a blessing man that is a
blessing it takes a special kind of
woman to be with somebody that does this
too because you know what I mean there's
different challenges so so that's great
man what would you guys say um are just
some things that you will give me a
heads up on in the marriage with the
lifestyle as well just a few tips to
hold on to maybe I mean take take a
break don't let work consume you you
know when you when you end the stream
and you get off you're off talk about
stuff she likes and she's into she's
interested in so like sometimes we'll
just talk about stuff my wife has finds
important or wants to talk about and
it'll be good for you you need to
decompressed and get out of that world
for a little bit recover so you can go
back in so you know try to you know have
a the work life and then have the the
home life and try to keep them separated
you're going to blend a little bit it's
going to happen but like try to focus on
things outside of the YouTube It's seen
for a little bit for sure for sure I
would say um I really believe everything
comes down to communication so being
able to communicate as best as you can
which is always a challenge I feel like
in marriages because there's a lot of
stuff that's unspoken a lot of um
expectations that don't get met you know
what I mean but being able to just like
have language to talk through that stuff
and be able to have the freedom just to
be honest with each other is like if you
start there it it's makes everything so
much easier because you're going to have
conflicts around things like money
because you guys value different things
or things like you know there's all
kinds of areas where you can um have
conflict but I think really having the
um ability to communicate keep the
communication as good as possible from
beginning then I think you can work with
that's awesome okay little change of
Direction here um obviously uh my
favorite Colts to go against is Islam
they're my favorite yeah not that I I
don't know why don't ask me why um they
are slow usually um can be mentally
taxing but for some reason I love it
they're my favorite group to go against
um what about you guys what is your
favorite Antichrist group whether it's
atheists Hebrew isites Islam what what
what do you guys find yourself more
enjoying destroying I guess probably the
atheist or the
secularists it's it's so
easy I mean but they have a lot of
influence right now so they need to be
addressed but I mean a lot of their
arguments are just really really bad and
it we can I can now effectively show
from research that their worldview leads
to more destruction uh societal issues
and Christianity is just a better
worldview so I can just show hey you're
not making the world a better place like
you thought that's a good point actually
because a lot of us just have like kind
of the basic arguments when it comes to
atheism or secularism like just
objective morality and stuff like that
you uh take an angle where you show
Christian Living and Christian ideals
actually have proven to make societies
better right I think that more of us
need to be uh get that in our bag that
type of argument needs to be in our bag
for sure AB absolutely not because ath
are convinced that if they can eradicate
religion not all but the the new
atheists or the militant atheists think
that if they can just get rid of
religion wenter this age of rationality
and Enlightenment and it's just not true
it's a myth and Christianity is actually
needed to sustain Western Civilization
yeah and so this I brought this up in my
debate with Lawrence Krauss and he had
no good reply no good response that's
awesome what about you John what's your
favorite group to dismantle humiliate
Expos it's the Tater fans it's the Tater
fans like it's weird man like honestly
like
um I I do a lot more one-on-one talks
with a lot of people typically you know
what I mean but like the atheist
probably you know what I mean because I
did it for so long too you know what I
mean um but I got sick of it at a
certain point too you know but but I
think man like honestly like I I love to
have a challenge where it's like people
that are kind of like your typ
postmodernist or something like that you
know what I mean like because they're
challenging because when we think about
atheism or Islam or Mormonism these are
worldviews you know what I mean top down
worldviews where it's like you can know
what they think by looking at the
worldview when it comes to your typical
person in culture it's not that way you
know what I mean because they I guess
there's a term for it called like
synchronism so they talk about a lot of
them where they're taking little pieces
from each different worldview they're
saying this is what I believe I love the
challenge of just hearing what they're
thinking and then trying to think of a
way where I can carer the gospel where
it makes more sense of look for the pain
points like where how it makes more
sense of what they want but they're not
getting from culture you know so that
that's where I really like to like do
like the yeah I guess I just like to try
to meet those people where they are you
know what I mean so that's it that's
extremely important now when it comes to
I've seen you guys go against Hebrew
Israelites atheists Muslims I've seen it
all and um the what the work that you
guys have done has been inspiring for
people like guys I I'm telling you I
take bits of all of you guys and I try
to make it into one beautiful chocolate
piece that is got logic and so you know
I contribute a lot to the chocolate you
contribute the most probably like 79% of
the chocolate I Pi there's no doubt
about that nobody can doubt that okay um
but you know so um we we see you know
the world like kind of um popularizing
being empathetic towards Islam
um turning to Islam or being a revert is
cool it's the polite thing to do um how
do we address I guess that what would be
some tactics addressing that on the
broad scheme um you know yeah I guess
showing is like showing Islam or showing
people what Islam is it's too rude uh
what are some tactics that you guys
think of of addressing this dude I mean
like show what they really believe what
their beliefs lead to I mean like so
many I've I I've heard so many
ex-muslims bring up Muhammad's marriage
to Aisha is one of the main issues like
is that what started to make them shake
their faith yeah yeah bring that stuff
up bring up their own sources against
them most of these Muslims do not know
what's in the Hadith they do not know
what's in the Quran and when you show
them they start to panic yeah yeah we
see it every day panic mode i' say for
Islam too yeah I think I agree with that
like a lot of most Muslims I talk to
just literally do not know about all
this stuff you know what I mean and then
they don't think it can be true so just
like exposure but like um I just kind of
think like again I just think that you
just kind of take different people you
know what I mean see where they're
coming from because I think it's easy
for us at least for me when I first
started doing apologetics I learned I've
read everything I could find that
William L Craig wrote you know I was
like I can tell you what William Lan
Craig would say about any topic right
like cuz he was a guy but
but but then you have all these
responses that are can responses but
they're not catered specifically for
that person because you really have to
get to what's behind the question why
are they saying this that that's when
you get to that you know and so like
that's why it's hard for me with like
when we have some sort of canned
response I mean you have to have some
sort of General guidelines or something
we don't have to but it helps you know
it's easier but yeah so anyways That's
my kind of thinking is like really just
try to get to what's behind it so that
way you can address the root problems
for people that's awesome okay now I
want to ask you guys about your channels
um in the beginning how you guys started
and how you guys started growing like
let's say like your first 100,000
subscriber Journey that that window
there was it hard getting there um what
was it like you guys were total noobs
rookies and getting good you started to
see the numbers growing what was it like
when you started noticing I guess the
numbers growing um you remember that
moment you're like oh yeah this this is
bringing it in you know talk about it a
little bit I don't know it's I don't
know I know it's hard to really say
there was an exact moment because it was
for me it's just really been a slow
progression I don't know I don't I have
had some times where I I saw a slight up
you always been slow and steady huh slow
I'm I like that though I'm making
Evergreen content I'm not getting the
sensationalist subscribers coming in
looking for like viral content people
are coming in because they want the
information they want the Evergreen
content and then they stick around and
that's that's a better longlasting model
than trying to hit the next you know
viral kick that's true that's true
you've constantly been growing too like
just yeah the tauris won the race
against T won the race yeah just just to
comment on that before you go John um
there was a moment in my YouTube channel
where my shorts started blowing up and
it started bringing in those type of
subscribers that they're looking for
shorts that like what you just said that
Viral you know highlight moment they're
not there for the long form content or
even the live streams and so it's like
he was like dude you got to slow down on
these shorts because that's going to
kill the channel that's right and I had
to do that I had to balance that out and
we see I noticed other people's channels
they grow off the shorts but their
channel is like stuck but they're like
cuz they're shorts nobody's really
they're not there for the information
they're there for a moment like a a
minute of entertainment type of thing so
that's right yeah 100% you um
yeah I guess it is kind of weird I just
remember hitting what my first video
that went pretty big was a video um
where I was responding to a Buzzfeed
video um from Lisa gunger where she was
talking about how um she left
Christianity and um and that was like my
first big video I remember when I posted
that remember the views were just coming
in you know and I was like w this is
crazy you know and so but it that was
the first time and then too when I got
like a little um yeah I just remember
just having that little I mean it was a
good like like I was like w this is cool
you know what I mean but then I tried
replicating that afterwards and it just
CU you can't replicate you know what I
mean so it's like that's why I feel bad
for people that have those big videos
like that cuz then you're like if it's
not really kered to the content you're
already doing it's just the moment and
then it's gone you know what I mean so
anyways um but yeah I just I mean I just
kind of remember like during the during
the pandemic is when my channel started
picking up a lot cuz I think it was
around 50k or something like that and
then after that my channel just started
picking up so that was when things sort
of really kind of kicking in a gear out
there that's awesome man so was there
were there any times where you guys were
maybe a little discouraged oh yeah in
the yeah for sure I mean like you put a
lot of work into a certain video and no
one watches it that happens for all of
us uh but you just keep going because
you real because at the end of the day
we're not doing this for the views we're
doing this for the kingdom amen and so
you know like I did a a series debunking
the documentary hypothesis and like not
a lot of people watched it but then I
was at a conference last year and what
happened some woman came up to me and
says I was in seminary my professor was
liberal they were telling me this stuff
and then I saw your series and it helped
me and so that's the kind of stuff we
really want to hear at the end of the
day 100% yeah yeah I think too for me
like I've had times where I was like am
I even making a difference because like
because it feels like people kind of you
know I don't know you just hit those
times sometimes you're like is anybody
even like really listening helping them
in their lives are they just getting
like a quick ride of entertain
entertainment you know and so that's
been you know tough for me here and
there you know I mean kind of think of
that but then you do meet people and
stuff like that you just he you know
what I mean and so that's a blessing but
um I mean YouTube's tough though if if
you don't you're if you don't love it
you will Beed out for you is it is a
hard game you know what I mean so 100%
you got to have the right motive you
can't be thinking I'm here to get famous
you got to think like I'm here to help
contribute to the kingdom or Rich your
PL to get rich stop stop right
there years before you even make a dime
anyway
yeah for sure sure well man I just uh
want to say thank you so much for
sitting down with me I know it's late
you oldheads are tired I see you guys
yawning you know we spent all our energy
earlier okay no but um this this was fun
man I cannot wait to do more stuff with
you guys man more laughs more videos
more fun more streams more talks like
this uh any last things you guys want to
say for the audience to look out for
maybe in your own particular channels or
you know anything you want to just say
to the audience well I mean yeah on the
topic we were just going over I got a
whole series of Summer coming out where
I'm going to just show all the benefits
of Christianity how Christianity ended
slavery how Christianity created Human
Rights created science I got a lot of
videos like that that's going to be fun
I cannot wait I'm going to get a whole
new notebook for that one what about you
John anything new coming up people need
to look for I guess when it comes to
videos I'm working on a video that's
going to be a long video it's going to
be on Islam so that's all I'll say right
now now um but it's going to be a long
video that I'm excited looking for that
too um and I haven't talked about this
publicly yet so I guess we'll talk about
it here um but I won't give details but
I'm also working on a film right now on
a movie that's yo what yeah yeah but I
haven't I haven't talked about it
publicly yet so he's told me I know all
about it that's crazy so yeah he just
weing with again this film
again about his little film little
director
but yeah but um I've been working on it
the last two years actually so it's been
a long time yeah it's been about two
yeah yeah and um but yeah working with
some a really talented team that's done
a lot of really good work movies that
people have seen you know everybody's
seen some of their movies stuff so
anyways I'm blessed but um yeah at some
point I'll announce it but yeah so you
got a little heads up yeah that's that's
a little dope you heard to he first man
you're here right here on God logic God
logic baby uh but yeah thank you you
guys so much make sure you guys hit the
like button this is inspiring philosophy
what do you mean make sure you guys
check them out subscribe to them if you
haven't done that already and also hit
the like button on this video And
subscribe to God logic apologetics for
more videos
peace it's God
it's it's
God it's God